[Music]
hello and everyone welcome to the final
session of the day in this room using
Hasek or vault with kubernetes my name
is Seth Fargo I'm a developer advocate
for Google cloud you might recognize me
from the DevOps versus sre series where
we say class sree implements DevOps I'm
excited to be here today prior to Google
Cloud I actually worked at Hashi Corp I
worked for our other speaker Arman Garr
who is the CTO and co-founder of Hasek
ARP and I will bring him on stage in a
minute to talk about vault just a quick
overview of today's agenda we have four
distinct sections you'll recognize them
by the colors that they're associated
with here we're gonna start with a quick
overview that Arman is going to give us
I know some of you might be familiar
with volt but we want to make sure that
we have a common baseline next I'll tell
you how to run vault in kubernetes as a
service we're gonna get really technical
so I hope everyone's ready there will be
a live demo then I'll show you how to
connect to that same vault cluster using
kubernetes applications from different
pods and different services again
accompanied by a live demo and then
finally Arman will talk about some of
the new and exciting things that are
coming on the vault roadmap in the
future so with that I'd like to welcome
Arman onstage
thanks so much I am hopeful we will get
through this session without running out
of disk space but fingers crossed
so like Seth said you know what I was
hoping to do was for folks who are less
familiar with volt start off with a bit
of a high-level introduction right what
is the sort of problem motivation right
I think we are all we're probably all a
little tool overwhelmed so you know
hopefully there's a good enough reason
for us to sort of consider adding yet
another so before we really start
talking about full I think it's useful
to talk about kind of the larger problem
right secret management as a whole which
is really what all attempts to solve and
so when we talk about secret management
I think the first question kind of the
most natural question is what exactly
are we managing what is a secret right
and so one of the things we talk about
is you know what is a secret and how is
it different from sensitive information
right so when we talk about a piece of
secret information it's something that
allows us to either authenticate or
authorize against the surface right so
an example might be a username or
password right we can provide that to
let's say a database to authenticate a
session against that database prove our
identity and then the database is
allowing us to request data from it
right similarly something like an API
token we can present that when we make a
call up to let's say you know Google
Cloud to you know read and write from
blobstore it's authenticating the client
it's authorizing us to actually do that
request and finally something like a TLS
certificate right you might not log into
a system exactly with the TLS
certificate but you're presenting it to
a client and that's authorizing you as
you know let's say dub dub dub Hasek or
comm and so it's allowing us to sort of
elevate ourselves into this trusted
position so any of these types of
materials right user and password
certificates are sort of secrets right
and the reason we want to keep those
secret is if they fell into sort of the
wrong party's hands they could use it as
a mechanism to authenticate themselves
or authorize themselves to perform
actions they shouldn't write they are a
mechanism of access and so those
mechanisms need to be tightly kept on
the other hand we have sort of sensitive
information right this is a little
different because it's things that you'd
like to keep confidential but can't
directly be used to sort of authenticate
right I can't use my customers social
security number to log into the database
right but it doesn't mean I'd like that
piece of information on the public
Internet so it's important to make this
distinction between sensitive things
which fault can help us manage and we'll
sort of talk a little bit about how
versus secret things which vault intends
to sort of put inside of it right you
use it as a database to hold on to
secret information so when we go from
saying you know this is what a secret is
till then talking about secret
management the way I like to sort of
talk about it is what are the set of
questions we want to be able to answer
right so when we talk about secret
management these are sort of the key
ones right how do our applications get
these secrets right my web application
boots it needs to talk to a database how
does it get a database password on the
same hand how do our human operators get
access right if I'm a DBA and I need to
connect to the database to do some
maintenance on it or you know fix some
issue with it how do I get that data but
same database credential then how do we
think about updating these things right
that we don't want them to be sort of
static credentials they live forever we
want to be sort of periodically rotating
them whether for compliance or just good
hygiene so how do we think about if I
change my database password what is that
how does that impact my applications
how's that impact my operators how do I
actually automate that flow then there's
sort of the bad things that could happen
right what if this thing is compromised
how do I think about revocation of
access right how do I do forensics on
who's done what when if I'm trying to
figure out are we in a compromised
situation where has this key leaked and
so what do we do in the event of a
compromised everything from you know
that forensic understanding to reacting
to it to rotating it so these are sort
of the hard questions that we'd like
answers to so the state of the world
when we sort of generally talk about
secret management as a problem is not
necessarily great right but we often
describe it as is secret sprawl right
this is a scenario in which secret
material is sort of sprawled all over
our infrastructure
it's hard-coded in source code it's in
plain text in our configuration it's
checked into github and plain text it's
sort of just litters everywhere right
and the challenge with this is sort of
it's very decentralized and we have very
limited access controls around it right
like who can access github an
organization you know probably anyone
with single sign-on right who can see
this plaintext configuration who knows
right it's not something we're tightly
access controlling
so we have limited access control around
it but also even worse visibility right
so then if we actually wanted to do an
audit of who all has looked at this
particular source file in this in you
know in github do we actually have an
ability to do fine-grain sort of
auditing and forensics on that so the
state of the world not necessarily great
when it comes to answering some of those
secret management questions and so this
is really where vault enters vaults sort
of original purpose was to try and look
at secret manager and say can we provide
a good answer to these set of questions
and so our goal is sort of at the top
line are starting with a single source
of truth right how do we move away from
this sort of decentralized sprawl to a
world where that is centralized and
managed in a single place right and so
part of this is really understanding
there's two different kind of consumers
there is our sort of application
consumers that want programmatic access
the web server is going to boot it wants
to fetch a credential and do it in that
sort of an automated way it's not you
know we don't want sort of a
point-and-click interface for that so
API driven automated access for
applications doing automation on the
flip side we still have our human
operators right they want something
nicer than an API they want command
lines they want user interfaces right
and so we want these two access patterns
to both be really optimized so that we
have the single source of truth and we
want a solution that's cloud friendly
right so what that really means is it
should be easy to operate it should be
you know not dependent on specific
hardware that we need to deploying it
you know in a private data center it
should be sort of pure software they can
easily operate in a cloud environment so
then when we translate that into okay
these are vaults top line goals how do
we actually achieve that you know the
sort of table stakes where things start
is just a secure place to put bits right
we want to you know put bits in have it
securely stored get those same bits out
right whether that's let's say database
username and password
and so in transit when clients are
talking to vault vault and you know
forces sort of end-to-end TLS you know
unless you change it by default ask for
the highest level of you know 1.2 and
everything at rest is encrypted and
managed with AES right so we have aes
256-bit both sort of encrypted and
authenticated so we can detect so
tampering of data at rest and this is
exposed to the end user a sort of a
hierarchical key value store so you can
apply some organization around folder
structure and grouping things together
in a way that may
sense for you so you know just make this
a little bit less theory a little more
concrete here's an example from the
command-line interface of you know both
writing and reading a secret so what we
see here on you know the first command
is we're doing a vault right against a
path secret foo it's like I said it's
sort of a hierarchical file system so in
this case secret is sort of a directory
and foo is the sort of file the leaf
node we're writing to and then we can
write opaque values so we're writing bar
is equal to bacon but you could imagine
that would be you know username is Arman
password is one two three four right as
an example and then we can come back
around use the CLI and do a read against
that same path so we're doing a read
against secret foo and what we see is
we're getting back bar is equal to bacon
so what this is really masking for us is
really thinking about as a client is
this encrypted over the wire right the
CLI is sort of talking over an encrypted
channel to vault you know hitting its
API and then vault is transparently
doing the encrypt as it writes it out to
disk doing the decrypt before it you
know provides it back to us as a client
so sort of doing the right things making
sure we're doing this with hygiene but
kind of making this easy as a as an end
user just to illustrate the sort of
equivalence of that here's the same
example as what we just did on the CLI
but hitting vaults API instead so like I
said one sort of primary consumer of all
is our applications or automation tools
and they want to consume it
programmatically with an API so here's
just a simple example of doing curl
where we're basically doing you know a
write against you know the path same
path of foo and encoding the data that
we want stored and then doing a read
back against the same thing right so
it's meant to be a simple restful api
that's easy to integrate with and so you
know that's sort of one level that sort
of table stakes is you know putting our
secrets somewhere that we know it's
encrypted we have you know audit logging
and access control around and all that
kind of good stuff but there's still a
bunch of sort of hard questions right
there's questions like you know what if
an operator connects Deval and you know
they're just find it annoying to have to
go to volt so there's gonna copy
everything out and put it in passwords
dot txt right so they don't have to
bother login or an application starts
and I'm sure we've never seen this the
first thing it does is write all of its
configuration out to standard out or
it's log file right so it just reads all
the Davis username password dumps that
to disk and ships that off to our
central login system in plain text
and the third sort of a classic case is
we hit a diagnostic error right it's a
500 error on rendering or we're in a
debug mode and it says you know here's
my database username and password by the
way if this helps you with debugging so
the thing you find is the entities we're
sort of giving these credentials to
whether it's applications or operators
do a terrible job keeping secrets right
so this kind of raises an interesting
challenge of you know how do we still
protect these secrets even though all of
these scenarios are you know
very likely so faults approach to this
the way vault thinks about this problem
is the challenge is we have these sort
of long-lived static credentials right
and the challenge with long live static
credentials is if they leak anywhere
ever right either through passwords not
text or through a log file or through a
dinah diagnostic page it's sort of game
over right we've arranged it as a zero
of some game right it's either a
perfectly kept secret or the secrets out
there and we're hosed right so how do we
sort of reduce the stakes right how do
we make this so less severe than all or
nothing and the way you have to do is
making Secrets ephemeral right you don't
want to have these long-lived
credentials that are valid forever
you want these things to be short-lived
time bound and things so that even if
they get log to disk oops right they're
only valid for so long before you know
we've moved on to a different set of
credentials so vault approach to this is
what we call dynamic secrets right and
the idea is sort of as opposed to static
secrets what we want to do is generate a
unique set of credentials on demand
right so when a web server says I want a
database credential we generate that
credential as employment time right
there we have a unique audit trail now
that ties us back and says this web
server has this unique credential and by
the way that's valid only for 24 hours
right so when the web server
you know renders a 500 diagnostic page
and leaks out our database password
we've time bound at how long that
credential is out before moving on to
another credential right and if there is
a breach and we know that that
credential is exposed we can revoke it
early so what does this actually look
like from the perspective of a client
they're just doing a read against vault
in the same way we just saw before where
they just did a read of secret foo and
behind-the-scenes vault is then going
out and talking to the endpoint right so
it's going and talking to the database
and saying create a new dynamic
credential right it's creating an audit
trail of that credential and then it's
providing that credential back to the
user right in this example I'm using a
database because I
it's sort of an intuitive one but you
can imagine this exact same diagram
where you replace the database with any
sort of endpoint system that supports
credentialing right a prime example
would be Google cloud itself right so I
want to give my application a credential
that lets it read and write from
blobstore as an example but I don't
necessarily want to give it a credential
that lives forever right I want to give
it a credential that's valid for 24
hours and I'm rotating that credential
all the time so in that same setting
vault would connect to Google cloud
generate a short-lived credential create
the audit trail and provide it to the
application or end-user maybe developers
doing some debugging right so the the
sort of example holds so so when we talk
about the sort of secret back-end
approach right so far we talked about
Google we talked about you know using it
with a database type system but it's
really a general idea right the general
idea is any system that uses
credentialing to manage authentication
or authorization has this similar sort
of a challenge right which is our
consumers need the credential so they
can consume the endpoint system but we
don't want these things to be static and
so our goal with fall is this is
actually a plug in point it's sort of an
extensibility point where over time
we're sort of constantly adding new
systems and adding support for them to
be kind of consumed in this dynamic way
so cloud providers are one great example
where they need API tokens to interface
with and maybe you're giving those to
humans maybe we're given those to
applications maybe your automation
systems are consuming it how do we make
sure that we don't have a forever token
in Jenkins right databases are a great
example system is a record that have
data but then you get into all sorts of
other systems right messaging queues
things like rabbitmq ssh right I mean I
think we could probably you know maybe
I'll spare everyone from raising hands
but you know I'm sure many of us have
seen the master shared PEM file with you
know a few hundred developers having
access to the same PEM that secures a
huge fleet right and so that's sort of a
an interesting challenge where we have
this shared mechanism this PEM file that
sort of too many people have access to
so the list sort of goes on and on this
sort of you know other stuff that we
don't have time to touch onto in much
more detail is sort of classic security
bread-and-butter right the sort of three
A's right as you'd expect vault has sort
of many different mechanisms to
authenticate against it so whether it's
an app running in kubernetes and we're
tying in to the plow
form its a VM just running in Google
Cloud or it's a user who's using LDAP to
authenticate there's sort of many
different authentication mechanisms all
of that comes into then sort of a
central authorization system so there's
a central way in Vault where you
authorize who's allowed to do what
so one huge goal with all is how do we
get to sort of least privilege you
should only be able to access exactly
what you need not sort of everything
because you were able to login so it all
has a very fine-grain off the Z system
that lets you scoped down who can do
what based on their sort of identity and
then lastly is sort of rich auditing so
we want to have that audit trail of who
did what when cool and with that I'm
gonna hand it back off to seth who's
going to talk to us about how we
actually use this and operationalize
this within kubernetes thank you great
Thank You Arman so the goal of the next
section here is to really answer two
questions why would i run this on
kubernetes
is it a good idea should i and how do i
do it the first answer is yes so we'll
move on to the second question so what
does this actually look like so the
following diagram here is also captured
as code on github
get up calm slash South Fargo slash
vault on gke but I want to walk through
it quickly together and before I do I
want to mention that this follows the
Hashi core best practices guide for
production deployments and production
hardening this was built in kind of
collaboration with some of the Google
security engineers as well as some of
the people on the the six security team
on kubernetes so it represents what we
like to think of as kind of the best
practices way to run vault on gke or any
kubernetes cluster so at the top blow
but we have some type of load balancer
and this example we're using cloud load
balancing because we're making this
vault server publicly accessible in your
own environment you might want to use
you know V pcs or VPN type networking
where it's only accessible in certain
subnets and then we have a highly
available vault cluster so we might have
three five seven servers all running
behind this load balancer and then below
that we have obviously the kubernetes
engine itself and then we're using
Google Cloud Storage as the underlying
storage back-end we also support Google
cloud spanner
and we are using Google kms to do the
initial encryption of the initial root
token and the initial unseal keys so
let's walk through some of those in a
little bit more detail so first we're
using a dedicated kubernetes cluster and
there's a few reasons for this but we
don't want vault running alongside the
same kubernetes cluster where your
applications are running in fact we
might even recommend running it in a
separate Google project that only the
security teams and the networking teams
least privileged access and to the other
clusters and other application
developers vault is just a thing in an
IP address we're leveraging Google Cloud
Storage again we could leverage Google
hub spanner but both of those storage
back-end support high availability as a
production deployment we need this to be
highly available there's no reason why
we wouldn't so we're gonna leverage
Google Cloud storage for our high
availability and our storage back-end
another advantage there is that we can
back that data up we can do replication
we can do customer provided encryption
keys as well we're gonna leverage Google
cloud KMS everyone taking a picture nice
we're gonna leverage Google Cloud kms
because our vault servers are gonna be
automatically initialized and unsealed
so those initial unsealed keys and that
initial root token eventually need to
get into the hands of an operator or an
automation system but we don't want them
stored in plain text so we're gonna
leverage Google Cloud kms to encrypt
those values and put them in the storage
back-end additionally we're leveraging
our own custom certificate authority for
TLS so you know one of the questions I
get is like oh why wouldn't you use
let's encrypt let's encrypt is amazing
but the problem is I don't actually want
to trust any certificate on the Internet
instead I want to use mutual TLS
validation and I want to use my own
certificate authority and only Trust
certificates signed by that authority
not even my system certificates this
helps secure vault and make sure that
only people with the certificates and
the proper certificate authority have
the ability to communicate with this
server additionally we're leveraging elf
for load balancing instead of using
something like the global load balancer
the GLB we're actually using regional
load balancers and the key reason here
is that an l7 load balancer is going to
do the TLS termination for us and we
don't actually want that we want vault
to do the TLS termination primarily so
that vault can handle mutual TLS
authentication but also we don't want to
decrypt data and then how
different Rhian cryptic connection on
the back end right using an l4 balancer
lets us pass that through directly to
vote and let volt let's vote handle its
own TLS and if volt ever rotates those
TLS certificates that it's using those
automatically happen we don't have to
also rotate them and an upstream load
balancer and then lastly and this is a
really key point we want to think of
vault as a service right so in my
internal operations team or my internal
security team yes I'm running vault
under kubernetes and I'm leveraging a
lot of the functionality that kubernetes
provides but ultimately I'm delivering
secrets as a service or secrets
management as a service so there's
vaults and an API and an IP address and
users ultimately shouldn't care whether
vault is running on a VM or a container
or bare metal or it doesn't really
matter so we really want to think about
this as kubernetes is providing kind of
the building blocks that let us run
vault as a highly available service and
we get some really cool benefits one of
them is you might see that we're gonna
leverage a stateful set here and the
first thing you might think of is like
wait this isn't a database there's
actually no state vault state is stored
elsewhere it's stored in GCS why would
you use a stateful set and there's a few
reasons why we might want to use a
stateful set first it gives us
predictable naming our actual container
names will be like vault - zero vault -
one volt - - this is really helpful for
debugging audit logging etc the real
reason though is that the stateful sets
give us exactly once some exactly once
semantics for free so as our servers are
starting up one will start up it will
unseal itself it'll be ready to go as
soon as its health check is passing the
next one will move along so we actually
avoid any real-life race conditions with
initialization or unsealing the same is
true for upgrading you don't want to
upgrade all of your vault clusters at
once right you generally want to upgrade
one and you know let the leadership
transition to a new server upgrade that
one etc until the entire cluster is
upgraded this is true with any software
using stateful sets a single change to
the the yellow file or whatever you're
using for the description of this
deployment automatically does kind of a
rolling update and if one of them fails
it'll stop we get a free circuit breaker
pattern so there's a lot of reasons why
we might want to use a stateful set here
additionally we're leveraging anti
Affinity rules so anti affinity roles
are occur Burnette ease feature which
led us
you things that affect or influence the
pod scheduling by default if we did not
have this yeah mo here kubernetes would
put all three vault containers on the
first node and that's not highly
available right if that one VM die is we
lose all of our vault servers so what
we're doing is leveraging anti affinity
basically suggesting to kubernetes or in
this example requiring kubernetes to
spread these all across all of our
available nodes or hosts this means if
one VM dies or two VMs die that our
vault servers the actual containers
themselves are spread across the node
pool so this adds an additional layer of
availability for us we're also
leveraging Auto unsealing the auto on
ceiling is also an auto initializer this
allows you to spin up a vault cluster
very quickly without operator
intervention and the keys will be
encrypted with kms and put in the
storage back-end we're also doing some
little things that make a big difference
for example we're giving the container
the IPC lock capability by default vault
supports memory locking this is
something that vault does in its
codebase containers don't give you that
privilege by default so we explicitly
ask kubernetes to give our containers
the ability to do memory locking again
just an added layer of security and that
our readiness check is basically asking
vault for its own health but we
explicitly want to make sure that our
standbys are also added to the load
balancer because this readiness check
here is going to determine when the
container is able to receive requests
from the load balancer and we want to
make sure that our standby servers are
also able to receive requests so that
they can forward them appropriately to
the leader notice that we're
communicating via TLS and then lastly as
we saw in the diagram we have this load
balancer again this might be an internal
load balancer in your own V PC or it
might be a public-facing load balancer I
don't recommend that but there's no
reason it can't be so with that let's
jump over to demo one so if we can
switch over to the laptop all right
here we go - everyone pray to the demo
gods here we go alright so the first the
first demo here I'm just going to show
you what it's like to run vault as a
service on kubernetes basically using
those exact EML files that I just showed
you first I want to show you I have a
kubernetes cluster here it's running on
gke
so we'll go to Cooper Teddy's dungeon
and we'll take a look at take a look at
the workloads here and there's nothing
right we have come on
we have no workloads here we haven't
deployed vault yet so what I'm gonna do
is over here I'll just take a look at my
my vault IMO and you can see that this
is very very similar to what I just
showed you on the slides there are some
additional pieces of information here
like I'm deploying a replica of a
replica set of three so I'm going to
have three vault servers again there's
that anti affinity that we saw before
and all of this is open sourced by the
way so don't feel like you have to
capture all of this right now we have
our first container which is our innit
container that's going to do the vault
initialization and then we have some
configuration for that container and
then we have the actual vault server
itself we're pulling that directly from
the docker hub again there's that IPC
lock capability and we're opening some
container ports that'll be available for
requests some basic memory and CPU
requests and then again some
configuration and here you can see where
we're actually supplying vault its
startup configuration via the magic
vault local config environment variable
so we don't have to worry about writing
out a file to disk we do this all kind
of in the environment variable so with
that let me go ahead and apply this so
I'm terrible at typing so I wrote fancy
scripts for you so what this is going to
do is it's going to just grab that
kubernetes endpoint and it's going to
apply Cupido apply dash F that
particular stateful set so what we
should see here in a second and this is
where everyone's prayers would be
helpful okay there we go
so these pods are actually starting up
and you'll notice that one of three of
them are starting up and that's because
we're using a stateful set which is
doing that one at a time exactly once
semantics so vault zero is running it
has some warnings but I think that's
just because it's booting up and if we
go back we'll start to see hopefully
okay vault one is starting as well and
then once we get to vault three this
entire entire replica set will be happy
and at that point we will have a volt
cluster because what's actually
happening under the hood is we're not
just running that vault container we're
also running that vault init container
and because this is a fresh new
container
it's actually creating the storage
connecting to the storage back-end doing
the initialization putting those on seal
keys encrypted via kms into that storage
back-end as well as the initial root
token and then the other servers when
they start up they look and they say oh
I'm already initialized they grab those
encryption keys and do automatic
unsealing for themselves if we were to
scale up our scale down the cluster
because the initialization has already
happened the initializer will just
unseal them and won't actually do the
initialization anymore so let's go ahead
and refresh this and check where our
status is I see a green checkmark which
is great I'm gonna go ahead and jump
over to Google Cloud storage here just
real quick to show you also this is the
storage bucket that I'm using and in
here you'll see the the folders here
core insists which are created by volt
but then the root token and the unseal
keys are both encrypted via Google Cloud
kms and then they're stored in this
Google Cloud Storage bucket so what I
want to interact with Walt is an
operator I need to download those via
like gsutil or via the Google Cloud API
decrypt them using Google Cloud kms and
the proper iam permissions and then I
can interact with vault directly so let
me go ahead and switch back to
kubernetes and I'll show you what all of
that looks like so I'm gonna jump over
here I have another magical shell script
which I will show everyone so this is my
magical shell script where I super can't
type but basically all of this does is
it grabs the CA certificate again we're
using a custom CA so putting the output
of that the address to my vault cluster
and I provision this wall cluster with
terraform so I'm delegating to terraform
there and then the token decrypt command
which is just a really long gsutil
command with some base64 and some
g-cloud KMS so what I'm gonna go ahead
and do is run this and again this is all
open source look-see I left myself this
note because I knew I was gonna mess it
up this is this is when you know you've
done too many demos so this takes a
little bit because it's actually making
like about five or ten API calls but
great now what I can do is I can
actually just run em grab well we see
that we have our volt token our vault
adder and our vault CA cert these are
magic environment variables that vault
reads I could also supply them via the
CLI but I'm lazy so now what I can do is
hopefully I can run volt status
and look at that we now have a volt
cluster up and running five key shares a
threshold of three it's in high
availability mode and this particular
node I hit is in standby so if we look
at that second to last line there we'll
see that this particular node that we
hit is in standby if I run volt status
again now I hit the active node
coincidentally because we're doing
round-robin load balancing on that load
balancer there anytime I make a request
to a standby that standby will
automatically forward the request to the
active leader so I don't have to know
where the leader is I just know the load
balancer address so this is how you run
vault as a service on kubernetes if I
kill one of these pods it'll
automatically restart it'll maintain a
quorum of three when it comes back on
line it'll be automatically unsealed and
it until that point it won't be added to
the load balancer as well which is why
that health check is so important so
with that can we jump back to the slides
awesome so that concludes the first demo
you can clap so now we have to forget
everything forget everything you just
talked about because the next section is
now that I have vault running how do I
connect to it from kubernetes but I want
you to forget that vault is running in
kubernetes think it's running you know
in some third-party service like like
Heroku or it's running on VM somewhere
forget that vault is running in
kubernetes instead volt is just a thing
available at an IP address everything
we're about to do can work with any
kubernetes cluster we're gonna use gke
but it could work with your on-premise
kubernetes cluster etc so again forget
that vault is running on gke or
kubernetes it's just a thing at an IP
address because the next thing we're
gonna do is create another kubernetes
cluster all right
clicky all right so very quickly we have
to talk about vault authentication
methods of Arman mentioned this very
briefly in the beginning authentication
in vault is the process by which users
or machines supply information to vault
vault verifies that information with
either internal data or some external
third-party and then assuming that is
valid converts that into a token with
policy authorization attached to it
here's an example of what that looks
like kind of in a graphic form we have
the vault server in the middle which
would you know receive a request from a
user or a machine or an application it
would then take that information to this
third party system that assuming that's
successful it would go to its own policy
engine and map that to a vault policy
and then return the token which is kind
of like a session ID or a session token
to the user which would then be used for
all future requests
it's like logging into a website you
know sometimes you log in with a
username and a password and your browser
sets a session ID but sometimes you can
also like login with Twitter login with
github right Voltas can ship so really
conceptually similar to similar to that
so what does that look like with
kubernetes well it's actually very
straightforward we just replaced that
third-party system with a token reviewer
API from kubernetes so a user or in this
case a service account representing a
user or a pod makes a request to the
hash record vault server with their
service account token their jot token
that jot token is given to the token
reviewer API the token reviewer API
verifies that jot tokens validity and
timestamp etc and assuming that's
successful it goes back to vault and
says yep this looks great
vault lang goes to its own internal
policy engine and says oh okay well the
things in the in this particular
namespace get this particular policy
attached to them here's a vault token
with that policy attached and this is
how the kubernetes off method works at a
very very high level there's technical
details here which we're not going to
get into but this is at a very high
level how this functions so to do this
you could write your own little bash
script or I've actually open sourced the
vault kubernetes Authenticator which
does this whole process for you it will
grab your service account from VAR run
kubernetes secrets the service account
job token it will post that up to the
vault server which is configured via an
environment variable it will get the
token back and it'll put it in an
in-memory volume mount for you so then
all your applications and services have
to do is extract that token from that
in-memory volume map so you don't have
to actually think about vault
authentication in kubernetes anymore you
could just leverage this and know that
the token will be there
assuming authentication was successful
it runs as an init container not a
sidecar container so it must succeed in
order for the
other containers to run then we leverage
tools like console template so despite
its name you don't need console to use
console template but console template is
a tool that is designed to provide a
configuration language by which we
extract secrets and credentials from
vaults and present them kind of on disk
or on a temp to score an in-memory disk
to an application or service without the
application or service knowing that it's
communicating with vault
many of you have you know brown fit
applications or even Greenfield
applications that you likely don't want
to directly integrate with vault you
might not want to call the vault API
directly using the golang library or the
ruby library instead you might want to
just continue to leverage a file system
or environment variables for credentials
and we like that abstraction because
then you're not tightly coupling your
applications to a secret manager instead
you're saying you know my config is on
disk or my config is from an environment
variable what console template allows us
to do is to provide that same experience
but under the hood as a sidecar
application it is actually managing the
connection to vault the renewal and the
acquisition of all of those secrets and
as we'll talk about in a minute what
happens when those secrets are revoked
or are rotated so I know what you're
thinking right what happens though if my
credentials change so I have this
sidecar application that wrote this file
out and my application is reading those
credentials from that file but how does
this console template thing actually
inform my application that my
credentials have changed so let's think
of a real-world scenario I have a
database credential vault tells me that
database credential is valid for 24
hours at the end of 24 hours vault it's
going to revoke that credential if it's
not revoked earlier by an operator at
that point my application or console
template has to go back to vault and say
ok I'm still authorized I would like
another database credential and it'll be
different it'll be a different username
and a different password so I'll write
that out to my config file but my
application is probably already loaded
it's config right most web applications
don't go to disk and read they're
configured every user requests they load
that into memory and they kind of cache
it until they're restarted or receive
some sort of signal so how can console
template signal my application to reread
its credentials we're in you know a
kubernetes world where all of those
containers are isolated well
an interesting feature in an alpha
feature right now in kubernetes is this
idea of shared process namespaces so
shared process namespaces are the
solution to this challenge and again
this is an alpha feature so it's
available in gke alpha and if you're
running your own kubernetes clusters
you'll have to enable it with cube admin
or a similar tool but this shared
process namespace allows our containers
to communicate with one another so
instead of having every container be you
know pit 0 or pad 1 they're actually you
know a root container and then these sub
containers with the ability to
communicate with one another so if we
give our console template process the
SIS P trace sis call the the security
contacts capability we can actually
leverage the standard UNIX tools like
pitov and kill to signal applications
and then all we have to do is provide a
command to console template and it says
hey when this file changes or when this
environment is updated or this secret is
revoked just send in this example hub to
the pit of my app we can leverage the
built-in pit of tool for that right or
perhaps it's something more complex
right we might have some you know 50
line bash grift that we have to run
because of some arcane you know Java
based application that is very finicky
right we capture that as code and
console template execute that for us so
this can either be as simple as a signal
or can be as complex as a very
systematic and procedural restart so
with that let's go ahead and jump over
to the laptop and we'll take a look at
what demo 2 is so what I'm gonna do here
is in the Google project switcher I'm
actually going to switch to a different
project so I have another project here
called my app so I'm in a completely
different project now remember one of
our best practices we recommended
earlier was that we have a dedicated
project in a dedicated kubernetes
cluster for vault and then we're only
thinking about vault as a service right
now it's just a thing at an IP address
so I have this other kubernetes cluster
where I run all my applications and
services for production all my web apps
oh my all my stateless services all my
stateful services they're all in this my
apps kubernetes cluster right now I
don't have any apps but we're gonna
we're gonna create a few in a second
all right so I have a few scripts here
the first is we're gonna set up the
kubernetes off method what the
kubernetes off method is going to let us
do is like we described in that diagram
it's going to configure vault to talk to
the kubernetes cluster with the right
certificate authority
so that we can verify via the token a
reviewer API the jot tokens so let's go
ahead and run that so it creates a CR B
and a few other things and then we
actually configure the kubernetes off
method and we create a new role for
authenticating to that configuration so
now at a very high level what this means
is when I have a pod in my cluster and
it goes to vault with its service
account that service account will be
authenticated to get a vault token back
with a predefined policy that I've
configured so this is configuration that
you could capture as code or you could
run it manually via the API but then
next what we want to do is we want to
configure our GCP secrets so the use
case here is that our mods example was
database credentials you might be you
know Postgres or my sequel etc one of
the other secret engines that we have
for GCP is the IAM GCP secrets engine
this lets you programmatically generate
both service accounts and service
account keys for GCP so instead of going
into the web UI and clicking and you
know or using the api directly you can
programmatically generate on-the-fly
tokens that are very short-lived for
interacting with the GCP api the same
way that you might generate like an AWS
access key but we can do that with the
GCP api so what i've done here is i've
just configured vault very briefly to
interact with those systems so the last
thing we need to do then is actually
apply our application so let me show you
what our application looks like so I'm
doing a bunch of stuff here all of
mostly is just because I'm really bad at
typing but I'm grabbing the the
credentials from our cluster and then
I'm setting the context and then I'm
applying this kubernetes ml file so take
a look at that yamo file he
kate's so there's a few things that I
want to point out here and the first is
that we're running a pod now we're now
where longer running a stateful set this
is just like a straight-up pod
it could be replicas but there's only
one at this point we're leveraging that
shared process namespace again this is
important so that we can signal our
application so console template can talk
to our other process we have a few
volume mounts we have our secrets this
is where console templates actually
going to write its configurations
because they're going to be secrets
there we have our own TLS configuration
this is how our pod talks to vault
because again we need that that
certificate authority and client-side
TLS cert and then the vault token which
is an in-memory volume mount where the
token will be written so that never gets
you know persisted to disk we have our
init container here which is again just
pulling from the docker hub and we have
a few volume mounts there we set some
environment variables like where is the
vault server where is it see a
certificate and that's going to run it
boot and assuming that's successful
it'll put our vault token at a
well-known path on disk slash home vault
and at that point all of our other
containers in this example console
template can then pull that container
that token from the in-memory filesystem
and interact with it so here we have
console template we've given it the sis
P trace capability so that it can signal
our other application and if we scroll
down here a little bit again same volume
mount same configuration and then here's
our console template configuration and
at the very end here you'll notice that
we have our arbitrary command our
arbitrary command is just to send kill -
hub to the pit of our vault demo app and
then as you might suspect the last thing
in our configuration here is our vault
demo app itself which is just getting
pulled directly from the docker hub and
actually all it does is log its own file
so it's not very exciting but it's
really good for demonstration purposes
so let me go ahead and apply this now so
now if we go back here we should see
this work load start to provision and
you'll see that the pot is initializing
and if I'm fast enough I wasn't fast
enough
if you're fast enough you can see that
it's waiting for the innit container to
run but if we take a look at this innit
container and I'm using stackdriver
logging here so you actually see the
logs directly in the Google console UI
here we see that you know a few minutes
ago or a few seconds ago that the init
container successfully stored the vault
token so it did that whole walkthrough
of you know going to the vol server
presenting its jot token interacting
with the vault cluster and then what we
presented to console template was just a
vault token at a well known path console
template then grabbed that vault token
and used that token to interact with the
vault API to grab our service account
key so now when I go back to my pod and
refresh this here we can see that both
console template and my app or running
and if we take a look at the logs for
all of these you'll notice that console
template sent a signal to my app causing
it to reload so at boot console template
detected a change in configuration there
was no config and then it went to some
config so it sent the hub signal to the
vault demo app the vault demo app or my
app in this log got that signal and
printed out a log line that it reloaded
what you see here is a soon to be
revoked access credential for
interacting with this particular GCP
project this is an actual IEM access
token for interacting with TCP I'm aware
of this
I will revoke it but it's cool so I'm
showing it to all of you and what's
happening is at some interval this token
just gets printed out basically every 30
seconds however at the end of about five
minutes what will happen is vault will
revoke that token so by default like G
cpi-m credentials live forever until the
human comes in and deletes them vault
actually enforces a lifetime and it
makes the necessary API calls to Google
Cloud to revoke those credentials when
time permits so unfortunately we're
running short on time so I can't
actually wait and show you that but if
we can switch back to the slides very
quickly so the last section now I'd like
to invite our mom back on stage to share
a little bit more about the vault
roadmap in the future so Arman
thank you awesome oh we are definitely
running short on time okay we're gonna
make this Lightspeed so thank you Seth
for walking us through a little bit more
hands-on them then I had a chance to go
to in terms of how we actually work with
it some of the stuff I want to talk
about so for folks that are maybe
familiar with Vall I've already used it
I wanted to give a little bit of a sneak
peak in terms of kind of where vaults
going sort of a little bit of our
thinking in terms of directionality I
think one of the things that sort of
become clear to us right is that when we
talk about this space right secret
management tools like fall integrating
it with these platforms is it's
complicated right and I think you kind
of saw a snapshot of that is it's not
exactly simple and obvious how all of
these things kind of come together
because it's a hard problem we're trying
to solve right we're trying to solve the
problems of application identity
brokering between many different systems
that don't necessarily understand each
other right like Postgres has really no
idea what you know Google clouds
I am model is and vice versa right so
what we're trying to do is solve this
challenge of each of these systems
implement different mechanisms of access
control and we're sort of brokering
between them right so it's a it's a
complex problem and so how do we start
making that sort of a little bit simpler
so one of the things we're starting to
work on within vault itself is you know
I joke you refer to as a sort of Clippy
for vault is that you can kind of see a
kind of a little pop in wizard in the
corner here which is you know it looks
like you're trying to configure vault
can I help you with that but you know
sort of interim more seriousness how do
we sort of help guide users through hey
these are the different kind of core
workflows in terms of how you configure
vault to understand kubernetes as an
authentication Macan how do you
configure vault to integrate it with
Postgres how does the sort of role
mapping work between this and so it's
sort of meant to be a you know
unobtrusive kind of wizard like
capability for different workflows that
you can sort of enable as you sort of
hit them to say hey please walk me
through how this is supposed to work and
have it be a little bit more interactive
as you're getting started with the
system another common challenge we see
with vault is how do I go from sort of
you know I think that's a great job
laying out you know at what's the best
practice deployment guide look like in
terms of isolating it with a separate
cluster and you know treating a sort of
just opaquely living behind a load
balancer and sort of building HJ and so
that an interesting pattern is how do we
go from providing that sort of service
vault as a service for a single
application owner or single sort of
group to all the sudden many application
owners many groups right we want to sort
of vault as a tenant well as a service
to be highly multi tenant between many
different potential groups or lines of
business and so one approach to this at
the kind of historical approaches you
lean on vaults very sort of fine-grained
capability and an authorization system
so you can segment out different parts
of the system maybe you say you know you
know Ange Starr is managed by one set of
people and marketing stars managed by a
different set of people right and we
sort of segment using all sort of
hierarchical folder structure another
sort of capability a different way of
thinking about it it's sort of full name
spacing and this is what's coming on our
roadmap is the ability to kind of carve
out entire name spaces within vault and
say you know I don't want to think about
sort of managing permissions of these
folders I want to just carve out a whole
namespace and say this belongs to
engineering this belongs to marketing
this belongs to sort of another team and
those teams can then sort of sub
administer these namespaces
independently so looking at as we go and
think about vault as a surface how do we
scale up the number of kind of consumers
the different sort of folks who can be
on boarded onto this service lastly is
you know some of the challenge around
integrating with all I think as said
highlighted is there's this sort of
tension between what we'd like to be
able to do is maintain sort of
operational flexibility right and not
tightly coupled our applications we
don't want all of our applications to
embed vault SDK and directly talk to the
API and have to be sort of highly vault
aware right that sort of limits our
operational flexibility so instead we'd
like to decouple that and use tools like
console template and you know scripts
like seth's auto initializer to sort of
thread through the right credentials so
that our app boots reads its secrets and
it's sort of blissfully unaware a really
common challenge those how do we do that
authentication before we can actually
read secrets right and so one of the
things we're starting to work on and it
actually just shipped this morning and
sort of beta is the vault agent right
and so this is sort of an optional agent
you can choose to run alongside vault
server which you sort of have to run and
what it does is manage some of that flow
for you the flow of fetching the jot
authenticating against vault
periodically reoffending you know call
integrating with tools like console
template
to be able to generate you know and put
configuration on disk in a more sort of
application friendly format so these are
some of the goals of the Asian is making
a sort of easier to authenticate easier
to manage token renewal easier to sort
of cache some of this data locally and
making those integrations a little more
out of the box so this is something the
just ship today so if this is something
that you find useful please feel free to
play with it so with that thank you guys
so much for for sitting through with us
and joining us and thank you to Seth as
well for helping
[Applause]
you
[Music]